media Madness over their reaction to the
terror attacks in Israel the New York
Times P publishing a story that referred
to Hamas as terrorist but then they
changed it to gunman and only changed it
back after criticism and an MSNBC anchor
had the goal to ask an Israeli mom whose
kids were kidnapped
this what are your feelings about the
the the attacks against Gaza right now
um
how can must say look you you're looking
for for a symmetrical situation and I
must say it isn't I can't be sympathetic
to animal human beings well they're not
really human beings who came into my
house broke everything stole everything
took my children from their
bedrooms and took them to the Gaza Strip
Israel never done that and will never
do so there is no symmetry I'm
sorry Greg you know Andrea Mitchell 40
years and she asked that question it's
amazing the asymmetry is like it's like
genetic or something among the media the
media also does this trick where your
commentary on an atrocity is greater
than the outrage they have for the
atrocity for example when we saw mobs of
cretans with their brand new signs uh
championing the Bloodshed and we
speculated or I speculate how did they
get those signs so quickly and
mysteriously how do they mobilize so
quickly the bottom feeding media threw a
fit over that which was missing after
the attack actually occurred it the it's
asymmetry and that that woman nailed it
oh yeah but she did it in a very
gracious and dignified way she didn't
have to um the I'm struggling with
something because we are reporting um 13
Israelis killed by terrorists but but it
might say 1300 Israelis killed 1300
Palestinians killed no
it's not the same there were 1300
Israelis killed by terrorists and the
resp in the response to the terrorist
attack 1300 Palestinians have been
killed I'm struggling with that a little
bit to try to figure it out because a
baby ripped from its mother's womb is
not the same as a Hamas terrorist
meeting his demise exactly I would just
add that Israel knows it has to act fast
because if it doesn't uh it's just a
question of time before half the World
Turns its back on Israel keep an eye on
the UN does the United Nations
during this period of turmoil pass a
resolution that condemns Israel that'll
be interesting Harold I look I've known
uh Andrea Mitch a long time and I know
of her commitment to Israel i i i
interpret this slightly different I
thought that answer I thought the
question was maybe not the most Artful
way to ask it but I thought the answer
was incredibly powerful what that mother
said of a kidnapped Israeli was that the
force we will enact and impose on Hamas
and on this region I'm willing to do it
even though I have a loved one there who
may be kidnapped even if that means
someone may be harmed so I I interpret a
little different I would not have asked
it the way Andre asked it but I don't
question her commitment to Israel I've
known her for I've known her for 30
years and there's not a journalist who
understands that region as well as she
does well I'll tell speaking to the
mother of a child of two children taken
hostage that was a tough one to ask I
agree hi everyone I'm Brian kilme I want
you to do me a favor I want you to click
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page this is the only way that I know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news by
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now